Well, good afternoon and welcome to Henderson Hills Christmas Eve
service. Would you all please stand what
an honor that you would come with your friends and your family to
worship with us on this day. Let's all
raise our voices and Praise
Jesus with joy and our hearts because our
savior has come.
but
battery receive her key
and let every heart prepare.
him and nature sing
heaven and nature
sing and heaven and nature
to the world
Us down together Joy to the World the savior.
you
know
And wonders of
his love.
and there's
one he's
hard time
here
we will see.
He will sing sing.
Joy to the World
Oh.
are here
the Lord than you.
in here
's the Angels pray.
Mary Joseph and the
land why?
this morning
I woke up the sunrise was beautiful this morning
if anyone was up to see it and I was reflecting
this morning on what this day means Christmas
Eve.
So that word eve it means we're on the brink of
something. We're waiting for something when the eve
of something and we're waiting for
Is the celebration of tomorrow that we are celebrating?
Jesus Christ Our Savior our King
the Messiah has come he's come
to this Earth as a baby.
Save us to be our savior.
And so the afternoon You're Here Waiting for
Tomorrow waiting to celebrate. I want
you to know the reason why he came.
Is where there is death.
He came to bring life eternal life.
Where there's pain he came to bring healing.
Where there's despair he came to bring hope
hope to your heart.
Where there's light he came to I'm sorry
where he's where there's Darkness. He came to push back
that Darkness to bring the light.
So I couldn't think of a better verse to read right now than John
1:1 through 5 and it talks about Jesus Christ the
word coming to be the light for
us. So let's read this together.
Says this in the beginning was the word.
The word was with God and the Word was God.
He was in the beginning with God.
All things were made through him.
And without him was not anything made that was
made.
And him was life and the life was the light of
men.
the light shines in the Darkness
and the Darkness has not overcome it.
best you've heaven
brilliant like this stars and the
wintery sky
joy of the father.
reach through the
dark shine across the
Earth
tragedies
no match for you from Great
Hearts of clothes. You saw
my story.
Became one. So we
sing Hallelujah the king of
keys.
and
you suffer to see
Right here.
you
soon will be coming with firing
inside. He will
answer some his own to
cut you.
showing
forever
you
here
You raise our
voices together?
afternoon
sing together as Christ Church Hallelujah
Halloween sing Hallelujah
see
At this time in the service, we're gonna invite our
kids fifth grade in under the front and
our family life Minister. Wendy Fuller is gonna lead us through
a story.
There you go. Come on. Come on
come up close all around. I have this book.
So you want to try to sit where you can see? Okay. There you
go. How is everyone have a
seat have a seat. There's plenty of room for all of you. Okay, so
Let me see your eyes.
What all of you you look so great.
Are you ready for Christmas?
Yes, so good to see you. We
have some more friends coming but as
they're coming I'm gonna ask something some of
you are so excited that I'm gonna have to ask you
to
take a deep breath with me.
Let it out.
Because I need you to be a good listener because
there's so many people even back there too who might
not be able to see and hear. So I need you up here, especially to
be great listeners Okay, so
I am super excited that it's Christmas, and I know
you are too.
and so
I think Christmas is amazing because
it's one of the times that we stop and
remember something astounding Benjamin
you want to stay here by me? Okay. Can you
all say astounding?
Yes, so this astounding thing
that we remember at Christmas is that God
came to Earth as a
baby and I have a story about that that I'm going
to tell you, but before I do.
I want to say something about waiting.
So have you ever had to wait for
a long time for something? Not your heads if you think you've
had to wait for things? Yeah, and so I was
thinking waiting for chocolate chip cookies
to finish baking has to be one of the hardest things
right? You could smell them you're ready
for them. But you just have to wait. They're not as good until they're
ready.
Or what about when you're getting ready to go on
a trip and you're really excited about where you're
going the countdown is on but you have
to wait, right? And then the other thing
I was thinking about especially and this one kind of
talked about it. I think tonight you are probably all waiting,
aren't you? You're probably really
excited about something that is
happening tomorrow morning. You're probably opening presents, right?
So all these things we have to wait
for just a minute. So when we
have to wait it's because we know
something great is going to happen that we
can wait expectantly and happily and
you know what,
Almost from the beginning of time God's people
were waiting. They were waiting for
this most important thing to happen. And that's
the story I'm going to tell you about. This is a book that many
of you probably have at home. You can nod your heads if you have a Jesus
storybook Bible. All right, good deal. Well, if
you can't see the pages, you can look up on the screen
and there there you will see the pictures. Okay. So here
we go. He's here. Everything was
ready.
The moment God had been waiting for was here at last
God was coming to help his people
just as he promised in the beginning, but
how would he come? What would
he be? Like, what would he do?
Mountains would have bound down Seas would
have roared trees would have clapped their hands.
The Earth held its breath.
As silent as snow falling he came in and
when no one was looking in the darkness
he came.
There was a young girl who was engaged to a
man named Joseph was the great great
great. Great. Great. Great grandson of
King David one morning. This girl was minding
her own business when suddenly a great
warrior of light appeared right there in
her bedroom. He was Gabriel and he
was an angel a special messenger from
heaven.
When she saw the tall shiny man standing there.
Mary was frightened.
I don't need to be scared Gabriel said God
is very happy with you.
Mary looked around to see perhaps he was talking to someone else
Mary Gabriel said and
he laughed with such gladness that Mary's eyes
filled with sudden tears Mary. You're
going to have a baby a
little boy. You will call
him Jesus. He is God's own
son. He's the one he's The
Rescuer The God Who flung
planets into space and kept them whirling around
and around the God made the universe with
just a word the one who could do anything at all
was making himself small and
coming down as a baby.
Wait, God was sending a
baby to rescue the world.
But it's too wonderful. Mary said
and felt her heart beating hard. How can
it be true? Is anything too wonderful
for God Gabriel asked. So Mary
trusted God more than her eyes could see and
she believed.
I am God's servant. She said whatever. God
says I will do.
Sure enough. It was just as the angel had
said nine months later. Mary was
almost ready to have her baby now Mary
and Joseph had to take a trip to Bethlehem.
The town King David was from but
when they reached the little town they found every
room was full. Every bed
was taken go away. The innkeepers
told them there isn't any place for you? Where would
they stay?
Soon marries baby would come they couldn't
find anywhere except an old tumble down
stable. So they stayed where the cows and
the donkeys and the horses stayed.
And there in the stable amongst the
chickens and the donkeys and the
cows in the quiet of the night. God gave the
world his wonderful gift the baby that
would change the world was born his baby
son. Mary and Joseph wrapped him
up to keep him warm. They made a soft bed of straw
and use the animals feeding trophies his cradle and they
gazed in Wonder at God's great gift wrapped
in swaddling clothes and lying in a Manger
Mary and Joseph named him Jesus Emmanuel, which
means God has come to live
with us because of course he had
So Jesus was born God had come to
Earth Emmanuel God With Us.
Will you pray with me?
Father thank you so much for Jesus. Thank
you for coming to this Earth as a baby. I pray
for every child here today God that they would know
the gift. You have given by sending your son
Jesus. May they receive him and the
eternal life you offer. I pray in Jesus
name. Amen.
Not only did he come as a baby but as
our King of Kings.
Parents, will you come and get your sweet kiddos?
Come over here.
We go ahead and stand with us again as we get to worship that King
of Kings this afternoon.
Came running there was Mercy In
Your Eyes.
To fulfill love and
Prophets to a virgin came the
word.
From the throne then this glory to cradle
in.
crazy
praises
spirit
three kind of Glory
matter just
deep space forever
you
some coming into
Cross glory to
keep your suffering you sought to
the other side knowing this
was our Salvation Jesus for
a sake you die. Let's Praise
Him.
self
crazy
Grace in The
King
rose of health and
healthy breath until that stone was
moved for good for the lamb
be conquered death.
the Terr
You know.
Church
you
was born
Lil Wayne
Go.
spels bubble
But his name in history.
you
Ever to the key.
of
King
it's an invitation to come and adore him
as king of kings.
to do this together
oh he
fade joyful and try
you
become and behold
him.
Born the king of angels O
come let us.
Oh come let us.
cry
see in exultation
Oh.
glory in the
US
he
cried
we
agree born this happy morning
Jesus to be
your
father now
in Flash
Oh.
Come let us hearts or
him O come
let us.
Shall be
wonderful counselor
his name shall
be Everlasting fun.
Shall be
peace.
here
you hear
you may be seated.
it
Let me again welcome you to Christmas Eve at Henderson Hills
one of my favorite nights of the year. Not just because it's
so beautiful and lots of smiles and fun and all of
the anticipation of what's coming later and tomorrow, but because
around here, we don't really just lean on
the cinematality of Christmas. We make it a worship Gathering.
That's what this is tonight. Hopefully you've already seen that
felt that it will be the rest of tonight as well.
If I haven't met you yet. My name is John lead teaching Pastor
here, which basically means I preach most of the time and so
if I haven't met you, please come say hello to me. I'd love
to meet you. There's also maybe more simple way
QR code in the seat back in front of you to just let
us know you're here. There's nothing that we're gonna spam you
with. We just want to know you're here care for you. Let us know
what you need. Please. Please encourage that among your
family as well. We would love to get a record of even
from out of state just to say thank you for being here with us. We we
do ask for your email on there. So I
thought it's only fair for you to get here my email. So John W.
At hhbc.com. And so don't don't even worry about giving
us yours because I'll give you mine. No worries about that. Now if
you're new to our church, you might be wondering what this whole thing is about Advent and
why we have candles up here all of that.
We've been walking through this season referred to as Advent. That word
is is a Latin root word. That means coming
or appearing and so what this
is is a celebration of the appearing of the Messiah
that we know as Jesus now, but but
back in the Old Testament, they were just looking forward to someone they
didn't know who it was and so, we now know it's Jesus but in some
way we're all so relating to their Waiting by our
waiting for his second Advent when
he returns and so we've got a sense of
waiting as well.
What traditionally has been used to Mark these weeks leading
up to Christmas is an Advent wreath of this or
some other form usually has candles that
are lighted weekly as you can see, we've already been through four weeks
each Candle on the outside symbolizes the
need we have in our hearts.
For the the longing of our hearts to
be fulfilled for for Hope for peace
for Joy for love.
And how that that Jesus is the only source for all
of those things that we have needs in our hearts.
Well, there's one more candle. Of course. That's the final candle in the middle and it
symbolizes what Jesus said about
himself in John 8:12 that he is the light
of the world.
That he brings the light of life.
You heard it earlier, Joe read it John 1:4 that
in him was life. And that life was the light of men
the light shines in the darkness. The darkness has not overcome
it.
This is a fulfillment of what Isaiah even prophesied 700 years
before Jesus was born that the the people
who walked in darkness have seen a great light.
This is what we're pointing to here that this is
the light of Life found in Jesus.
Yet even as we come to this one tonight.
Where we'll light this final candle celebrating Jesus bringing light.
The reality is that many of us.
Don't feel that life that God's
word talks about.
Like you might have walked in here feeling pretty empty.
You walk around in this supposedly joy-filled time
of the year and and you're just
not there.
You don't have that Instagram worthy kind of life that everybody
else posts about because yours is just not there.
Even singing the lines from that song. We just sang.
Oh Come All Ye Faithful joyful and triumphant what
you feel instead is faithless Joy
less
defeated
you might even wonder.
If God wants anything to do with your messy life.
Well, if I got good news for you friends that he
does Christmas in itself is
God's yes to that question
that I just asked.
Does God want anything to do with my messy life Christmas is
God's answer screaming? Yes that
it Christmas is for the weary Christmas for
the messed up. Christmas is for the broken.
Christmas is for you.
Because remember not only were those in the Old Testament walking in darkness
as they waited for that Messiah to come. We are
walking in darkness to
We are the ones who chase after all these false
sources of light.
That only lead to further darkness and more Brokenness and
never satisfy. That's what makes our
lives dark and empty. That's what makes us feel
like we do. It's a problem that God's word calls sin.
It's what separates you from that light of God.
That's talking about your own sin. Of course that brings Carnage. We
all know that we have all look back at our history and we know
that our sin brings hardship, but it's also just
sin in general.
That this world is fractured. It's not the way it's supposed
to be and in general sin brings struggle.
people die
we experience loss.
We get sick.
But hear me, that's the world that Jesus entered into.
See don't get this picture like maybe from that nativity scene
that you have at the house. You put out every year that that was some
kind of perfect vision of life that everything
was great the star the Shepherds like it
was all perfect. No.
Jesus was born in the middle of nowhere.
to pour nobody parents
in the midst of farm animals
This was the world that was full of pain and
Brokenness the Roman Empire people were
feeling oppressed. They were lonely. This was
all circling around this yet into that world.
Is the world that the Son of God the word of
God took on flesh and dwelt Among Us.
He became a baby to identify with our
Humanity.
He could have stayed away. He could have stayed out there above
the mess, but he entered into it and became
a baby to feel it with us.
But here's what we can do with Christmas we can leave it there.
But that's not the end of the story, right?
Jesus didn't just stay a baby. He grew
up and lived the perfect life that you and I can't live
now. He then died the death that you and I deserve
because we can't live that life and then he came out
of the Grave on the third day to defeat sin and death that we
could never defeat on our own. That's the whole story of
Christmas that Resurrection light has
come.
And darkness cannot overcome it anymore.
Darkness brings death
Jesus defeated death. The resurrection light has come.
So whether hear me whether you think you have it all
together tonight or not.
That's actually what Christmas is all about. Charlie Brown, right?
The light has come and the Darkness cannot overcome it
and he came for you no matter how dark you think your life
is he came?
Mess and all he came into it.
But I want to be clear about something.
His salvation that we're talking about here is not automatically applied
to everyone.
We're not universalists.
because even when Jesus was born into his Jewish Family
many did not believe who he truly was.
They rejected him they refused to
believe that he was the true king and savior that they
need.
And it didn't matter how faithful they were to their Jewish heritage.
It didn't matter how good of a person they were at that
point. It didn't matter because Jesus is the only way to
the father. He's the only way to Salvation the only way to
light the only way to life.
So the question we need to ask tonight is have you rejected
Jesus?
Now I'm going to assume.
In most cases here tonight. It's probably not an active rejection
of Jesus because because you came to Christmas
Eve here, maybe your grandma drug you
here, but but I get like most of you would agree with
pretty much everything I've said tonight.
Like you grew up in church.
You have a good track record. You
didn't do anything too bad. I mean you're way better than the jerk down
the street at least right? So you're not a bad person. You're a
good decent human being living in Middle America here and
everything is seeming to be okay.
So you're not actively rejecting Jesus, but you might
have passively rejected him.
By not acknowledging that he calls
the shots in your life.
That he actually has the the
what what you need to follow in your life is
his way not your way. You still live as if you're
in charge.
And you're walking in your old life just
like you used to.
That is rejecting Jesus.
Because listen to what John 1 continues to say in verses 12
and 13.
It says to all who did receive him.
Who believed in his name he gave the right to become
children of God.
But notice who were born not of
blood nor the will of the flesh nor the will of man, but born
of God.
So again, you might say you believe in Jesus.
But the biblical concept of faith of belief
is more than just agreeing with information.
Like you agree that I have a red shirt on I guess so cool. I
believe that. Yes. This is way different. This is Faith.
This is trusting with your whole life and your
whole future.
This is what leads to what he just said being reborn.
Now you might be like Nicodemus in John 3 saying well, how can I enter back
into my mother? Like that's confusing, right? Yes, of course. He says we've
all been born physically. Once what we all need
though is to be reborn spiritually.
To be made new that the the Creator God would
remake us from the inside out
with a new heart a new way a
new desire from what God has planted in
us that's different.
That's what we need. That's what true salvation is. And that's
what we all desperately have to
have to be with God.
But that only happens when you place your trust in jesus' life
death and Resurrection in your place for your salvation.
That's the only way this Light of Christ will come
into your life and make you his child. I
mean just just stop and think for that for a second. He says
be child of God. You'll be a child of God.
Think of the privilege that is for the the
son of the king the daughter of the king of
any Kingdom to be able to just walk right into the the
king's quarters.
To have full access no matter when whatever
they have every privilege of the child of
the king.
That's what he says.
you will have
When you're reborn into his family spiritually.
To be a child of God.
Acknowledge him as your king and his
work in your place and you will
be saved.
Here's the thing. You can't you can't create that light in
yourself. You can't spark like you're holding that candle you you can't
make that thing light up on your own if you can we need to
have conversation later, but you see you can't make that happen.
You can't make this light shine in your heart Yourself by
being good enough or anything like that. It's been said this way the
light isn't something that has sprung from within
the world, but rather has dawned upon
it.
The coming living dying and raising of Jesus
is what he did for our Salvation that we could not
do for ourselves merely by being good.
The gospel is not good advice pointing out the things
we can do to make ourselves right with God. It's good news informing
us to the things God has done on our behalf.
That's the whole point of what we celebrate tonight. And every time
we gather it's not how much we have done. Look at
how great we are. It's like look how bad we are that we
needed somebody to do it for us.
And God himself has done it.
And so how will you receive Jesus tonight?
Maybe you don't have any relationship with him at
all. Will you receive his work in your place as the
gift of Grace? It was meant to be.
To see him as the light and the life you need and turn from
your sin and turn to him. That's what he would love to
give you this present of salvation.
But listen, this is not just for unbelievers believer. Listen, this is
the same truth. You hear over and over
and over, but will you be freshly reminded tonight?
Of how the tender Mercy from on a high has dawned
upon you.
how that sunrise
it's like Joe talked about this morning how how the sunrise has
shined?
And it's glimmers of light and we see it for the first time
that the darkness has not overcome it.
That the mornings showing up.
And someday that day is coming in full.
That is what
We Believe changes everything
That the Light of Christ let that believer let that
change everything tonight.
But not just tonight every night, right?
Until Jesus comes back again.
That's why that candle of light is the final candle of Advent that
we will light this season. It's the one representing Jesus
his light that he is, of course
the hope and the peace the joy and the love of every
longing heart, but he's also the light and
so I want to invite the steel and family up here tonight to lead us
through that Brandy serves in our
student Ministry other important disciple making Ministries both
inside and outside the church. They're gonna light that final
candle read some scripture and
pray for light to flood Our Lives
This is Isaiah's 60 versus 1 through
3 and 18 through 20.
Arise Shine for your light has
come and the glory of the Lord has risen upon you
for behold Darkness shall cover the
Earth and thick Darkness the peoples, but the
Lord will arise upon you in his
glory will be seen upon you.
And Nations shall come to your light and Kings to
the brightness of your Rising.
violent shall be
no more hurt in your land Devastation or
destruction within your borders. You shall
call your walls salvation and your
Gates praise.
The sun shall be no more your light by
day nor for brightness. Shall the
moon give you light but the Lord will be
your Everlasting Light and your God Will Be Your Glory.
Your son shall no more go down nor
your moon with draw itself.
For the Lord will be your Everlasting Light and your
days of mourning shall be ended.
Would you please pray with me?
Dear God we thank you so much for this Christmas Eve where we
can gather together and praise you as a church family. We thank
you that you sent your one and only son to save us from the
price of death and to defeat sin and darkness forever Lord It's
So miraculous how even all the way back in the
book of Isaiah. You promised us this gift of eternal
life.
We thank you that you are a god of unconditional Covenant and
that no matter what we do you will always fulfill your
promises.
God we know that it can be really easy this time of
year to get caught up in the Stress and Anxiety that comes
along with the Christmas season. I ask that you would please
draw us back to the true meaning of Christmas and that
you would just help us really rejoice in the fact
that we are not slaves to sin anymore.
I also pray for the people who are hurting this Christmas. I ask
that you would just wrap your all-powerful arms around
the Brokenhearted and shower the hurt Souls with
your goodness and love.
God this year. We really want to come back to your feet. We
pray that you would yearn our hearts to really understand
what it means to have the true Spirit of Christmas and that
you would show us how to love like you did this holiday
season. We pray all of these things in Jesus name.
Amen.
Thank you, Steven.
So we are going to now.
Symbolize how this light?
Of Christ comes to each one of us.
So you have the candle hopefully on the way in
you grabbed one. If not that you can quickly go find one.
But in a moment, we're going to have a few of us take the
light from the middle candle.
The Light of Christ and we're going to
begin Distributing that light no notice
how this works right? It's person to person.
That's how God ordained this to work.
And so as you believer have received
the light.
It is now our responsibility to turn and give that
light to all those around us.
Next to us in front of us behind us.
Let's live out what Christ has called us
to with his light. So if you're going to
distribute it go ahead and come on up and begin your rest
of you would stand with us if you're able and we will begin to
sing as we see God share his
light.
You the
stars are
brightly shine.
Long lay the
world in sin
and never applying.
to hear and the
Soul felt
it
Her through the weary
World rejoices
for Yonder breaks.
Oh here.
the angel
s
when Christ was born
his law is
And is Gospel is
peace?
Shall he
break for the slaves?
And in his name?
sweet hymns of
joy
in grateful chorus ways.
We
let all always.
Here here.
when Christ was born
really wish you could see this view up here. We appear get
the privilege every year to see this view. It's
an amazing picture.
but I want you to see how
Your one candle whenever it was just one
in a dark room.
Did light up?
A little bit around you, right?
But look at how all of our candles banded together lights
up the whole room.
This is what the church is meant to be. We together
the Light of Christ in US
individually in us together.
Can light up a very dark place. That's what
God wants for us as we pass it on to others. He
then lights up the world as we are
the light of the world now.
through us
but also want to bring another
image to us and when you be careful, so parents might
coach your kids on this one to blow the candles out now and want
to sit on this just for a second once the candles are
blown out. So let's go and do that.
Okay, so you see now?
The darkness when the light is gone.
So this is what the world feels like. This is what
people walk in darkness feeling and so
we have that now.
Just as a feeling for that. All right, you can bring the lights back up now.
as we
celebrate it tonight. That's our hope.
Is that you see the Light of Christ through his word
through the gospel and through his people.
And so we want to invite you to be back tomorrow morning
10:30 will be here actually over in the activity center down
the hall over there be worshiping unique way that
way and then next Sunday on January 1st. We're
going to kick off a week of prayer as a church where we
have a value called desperate dependence that says
God we rely on you to do everything and so we're gonna start 2023
off with a week of prayer. I'll explain more about that
as we get to that on January 1st, but we hope to see
you again soon. Let me pray for us as we go
to the rest of our night. Thank you God for this.
Thank you for the blessing of families. Thank you for the blessing of
of friends. Thank you for the blessing of the gospel
and the church. We pray that now as
we have seen this picture of light.
That you would pour it into our souls that it would
shine brightly through US individually and through
us as a church.
May we keep our eyes fixed on you. Maybe remind us
of what we have in you God.
And send us now for your glory to the
ends of the Earth to our neighborhoods to our workplaces to our
homes with the mission of light on
our lips. Thank you God.
May you receive the glory in all of this in jesus' Authority
we pray. Amen. Amen. Love you Church
Merry Christmas you are sent.